cheryl is coming to us live from
vacation
i was gonna say cheryl is somewhere not
working except for the next four
minutes i follow her on instagram like
she's on vacation right now ah
okay well enjoy well here's the thing
though i mean
for this movie free guy i wore the free
guy shirt i can't i
i bribed my husband with beer and the
children with sugar to be here
i mean the movie is that good
congratulations
well thank you thank you for
interrupting your
i'm sure is a much needed vacation to
speak with these two yahoos we really
appreciate
but again congratulations on this movie
it is everything we all need right now
um i mean
you're really bringing families together
when you think my most kids were like i
want to see deadpool we can't let you
see deadpool and then you made free guy
and it's a movie that we can all see
together did you do that on purpose
um i don't know if we did it on purpose
i honestly was only led by the story we
i loved the central theme and story of
free guy i felt like it was super rel um
uh
uh pertinent for right now in the times
we live in and this constant sort of ink
black news cycle that sort of
repeats itself over and over again and
it felt like the perfect antidote to
that so
no it had nothing to do with that as
much as i just really wanted to tell the
story and
i think sean was had a similar place
yeah it struck us as this
very compelling idea but we never wanted
to make just a video game movie
i did want to make a movie that would be
as warm as it was
funny and when you can combine those two
elements those laughs
and those touching moments and do it in
a story that is appropriate for
us to watch with our kids and our
parents yeah
you know we didn't set out to do that
but it
thrills me whenever something i've made
can bring families together it's not my
kind of driving motivation
but it is something i love about this
job and the kinds of things i try to
make
yeah there was definitely a beautiful
balance because i think there's it's a
little bit insider some of the kids will
love
some of the gamer cameos and references
and all the other cameos it was
brilliantly done
um quick question you know we're talking
about superheroes and super powers what
would you say ryan and sean
are your superpowers as people
for power i don't know i to
you know years ago this is sort of weird
but interesting i took a conflict
resolution
workshop and man oh man that changed my
life like it really allowed me to kind
of communicate
in ways with p with people who were not
easy to communicate with
so that i would say it was a bit of a
superpower and a bit of a kind of a hack
uh in my everyday life definitely yeah
um
i mine would probably be an
interpersonal superpower too
um as part of my job i need to be
present with whoever i'm engaging with
to get the best out of them
so and by the way that applies to each
of my four daughters
my wife of many years my actors my
cinematographer my visual
so you know i bounce around a lot but if
i'm talking to you
i'm gonna be right here with you and i'd
say that that's been a bit of a
an ability i don't know if it's a
superpower but it's an ability that
served me
he's like tom cruise when he's talking
to you it's laser focus that is true
it's like i'm into your soul yeah i can
feel it i can feel it
all right next junket you need to do it
up here okay
clearly sounds good where are you at
like hottest country
no i mean at uh
the marriott up here it's good nice
oh yes i see on the umbrella behind yeah
even if you are
trying to not reveal that you were on
vacation i know
listen it's either that or the blazing
sun so i took this
where you look fantastic and relaxed
you guys do thanks for such a great
movie it is amazing and it's uh i'd say
oscar i'm gonna say oscar there you go
okay take it sure
okay thank you so much cheryl thanks for
interrupting your your vacation for us
and now go get the husband off the beer
and the kids off the sugar yeah
okay right right right
take care guys bye bye